(upbeat music)
- There's no place like home.
And that's why we're
celebrating as many hometowns
as we can, all across the
country, all season long.
Next up is Portland, Oregon,
where culinary professional
Judiaann Woo calls home.
I hear she makes it her mission
to know all the best
restaurants and chefs in town.
Now that's a woman after my own heart.
Let's watch.
- Hey, Drew.
It is Kara Mack, host
of K2's Afternoon Live,
your sibling show in Portland, Oregon.
And I know you are
celebrating hometown spirit.
Well, no one has more hometown spirit
than our very own Judiaann Woo.
Judiaann, share with people
why Portland's so awesome.
- [Judiaann] Portland is my
hometown and I love it so much.
There are so many amazing
places to eat and drink,
plus scenic beauty,
and the most passionate
and creative people you will ever meet.
- And you're gonna show
it off for everyone.
So we're gonna send you off.
Have so much fun.
- Welcome to OMSI.
OMSI stands for the Oregon
Museum of Science and Industry.
It's got something for everybody.
You learn about the earth, the universe,
and everything in between.
We have here giant
Australian walking sticks.
This is one corner of the museum
where they have actual live creatures
that you can interact with such as these.
Say hello to Drew.
I'm here at Toki Restaurant
in the heart of downtown Portland.
And behind me is Chef Owner, Peter Cho.
He's doing his take on the most delicious,
crave worthy Korean-American classics.
This is like, you know, portable food.
So good.
- Yes.
- Well, Drew, that was just
a quick peek at Portland,
the city we love so much.
We can't wait for you to come visit.
See you soon.
- Hey, Drew.
My name is Tatiana Inise.
I'm the elementary
school teacher right here
in Washington, DC.
Now, DC has my home for
the past couple of years,
and I love it here.
One of the things that I love
about DC is it's rich history
and culture.
Now, we're about to go
check out Union Market.
It's my favorite place to
hit up right after work,
so let's go.
My first stop when I come to Union Market
is I always go to Puddin'.
Puddin' is a New Orleans
Southern comfort food
all wrapped into one.
Honestly, the bread pudding is delicious,
but everything on the menu is delicious.
I normally order the shrimp
and grits or the etouffee.
So if you're Union
Market, check out Puddin'.
We're here at Meridian Hill Park.
But some locals actually
call it Malcolm X.
Little known fact, I didn't even know
it was called Meridian Hill park.
I've always referred to as Malcolm X park.
Now on Sundays, they have a drum circle
and it's absolutely beautiful.
Like live music on a Sunday.
Why not?
It's my favorite place to come
when I just wanna chill out,
wanna walk my dog, go for a run.
It's just the peace in
the middle of a city.
All right, Drew.
That's just a little snapshot
of the Washington DC.
I hope you love it as much as I do.
Listen, next time you're in town.
Hit me up, girl.
I'll see you soon.
- Howdy Drew, I'm Pam
Minick here at KTVT CBS 11
in Fort Worth Dallas, Texas, along
with Chief Meteorologist Scott Padgett
and what we love about
this area of North Texas,
it's the perfect blend of
cowboys, cowgirl culture,
and entertainment.
Now we're headed to see
the Dallas Cowboys because.
- CBS 11 is your Official Cowboy Station.
- We're at the home of the Cowboys,
Dallas Cowboys Football Team, that is,
and my favorite part of the team
are the Dallas Cowboy Cheerleaders,
who have a message for you Drew.
- [Cheerleaders] Welcome
to AT and T Stadium.
- How about those moves, Drew?
You know, even when it's
not football season,
you've got to see the Cowboy's Stadium,
the size, the scope of it,
the artwork, the memorabilia.
It's worth seeing.
This is the National Cowgirl
Museum and Hall of Fame
in Fort Worth, Texas where
women who shaped the west
with their can do spirit are recognized.
And I'm proud to be one of those honorees.
Dr. Diana Vela, what makes
The Cowgirl Museum a must see?
- We are the only
institution in the nation
that honors those women
who are shaping the west
and changing the world.
Where else can you see
Miranda Lambert's guitar,
a Game of Thrones saddle,
and Annie Oakley's shotgun
in one place?
- Well, Drew, that's just a little taste
of what makes Fort
Worth Dallas so special.
I hope you love it as much as I do.
And I can't wait for you to visit.
You know, they say that
everything is bigger in Texas
so I can't wait to show you more.
("The Drew Barrymore Show Theme Song")